I am Canadian but I do not speak French
hey Ron I'm Allie sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen on today's what I in a
date you to review we are going to be
talking about Natasha
oh say on I think that things say your
name I see the little I saw Teague and
the bad Canadian of me is like trying to
think French
but I'm struggling so girl I'm really
sorry if I said your name wrong but
Natasha is known in the YouTube world
for a lot of kind of fitness related
content some kind of health nutrition
she's also been very open about her past
struggles with disordered eating over
the last so while Natasha's talked about
her transitioning to intuitive eating
and that lifestyle especially given that
she's coming from the fitness industry I
really think that's so important because
it's so heavily steeped in diet culture
but if you just look at like a year ago
a lot of her videos still have titles
like you know loose fat stay strong and
loose fat and keep it off and things
like that so these are these are
concepts that are heavily steeped in dye
culture and our very weight centric but
if you circle back today you'll see
titles like how Fitness ruined my health
as well as somewhat eating a day about
intuitive eating etc I have watched a
bunch for videos now I think she's super
fun she's insightful she's clever
she's got lots of energy but is Natasha
fully embracing an intuitive eating
lifestyle well let's take a look at her
day you guys don't know how unbelievably
I've made so much canola that it fills
all of these jars in fact I made so much
they overflowed and I've got my reserve
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so love granola that looks delish it
actually looks a lot like the granola
that I have in my cookbook that my
fellow cookbooks so I'm loving and also
it looks like there's chocolate in there
so looks like a good start to the day
but yeah she's got some slow digesting
carbs and some fiber from the oats and
the fruit and the nut butter in there
also that's gonna keep her satisfied
longer and helps stabilize her blood
sugar I also see that there are some
healthy fats in there from the peanut
butter also peanut butter is life let's
be real I think if I was being like
really nitpicky I would say she could
have a little bit more protein for her
breakfast because research has shown
that it may help to reduce mindless
snacking and also just kind of provide
that satiety factor I think a lot of
people struggle to get enough protein at
breakfast and then they really kind of
have a massive portion of protein at
lunch and dinner when really the maximum
amount that our bodies can utilize for
muscle protein synthesis is about 30
grams per meal or snack so I really do
like to see us pacing things out but in
general I think it looks like really
really tasty girl take some time to take
please no but seriously I think
prioritizing our health often starts
with a really thoughtful morning routine
it just sets the tone for the rest of
the day so always give yourself enough
time to eat and get ready and have your
morning BM our body has a bit of an
internal clock and if you expect it to
go at the same time every day you can
get into a nice little routine this
ultimately helps ensure regularity and
keeps you on track of your digestion
okay so I like skipped through a bunch
of stuff that did not involve food and I
don't know what time it is right now
when she's doing her workout it seems
like a lot of time has passed since she
had her granola and I don't know about
you but I could not be squatting that
matrix or whatever the heck she's doing
without any real protein in the morning
I probably be really really hangry by
now now whatever time it is my
recommendation is before a workout you
want to have a meal about one to two
hours before you work out so that you
don't get too crampy ideally something
with some combination of carbohydrates
and protein if it's gonna be a lot
longer before you get to train then you
could have a small snack beforehand
ideally something with some
carbohydrates just to give you a little
boost of energy and then focusing on the
carbohydrates and the protein
post-workout so in Tasha's case that
granola that she had would make an
amazing pre-workout snack
assuming that of course she's not
training hours and hours and hours later
but she's got that combination of the
slow burning complex carbohydrates for
satiety as well as the quick burning
carbs for energy
[Music]
that's brutal that is brutal girl so
much respect kid not do that okay well
there's the snack action and I agree
you know electrolyte drinks or sports
drinks are a good way to replenish
electrolytes and also to give some fast
accessible carbohydrate based energy but
here's the deal if you're doing a long
intense workout something that's longer
than an hour or you're working out in
the heat and you're sweating a lot then
yes you could benefit from a sports
drink however if your workout is less
than an hour or you're not sweating too
much then water is typically fine if you
really want the benefits of the sports
drink but want to save money then of
course this could easily be a banana and
some water with a pinch of salt in it
Mario is saying is that our bones repair
when we give them moderate stress so the
same thing we do with muscles where
we're looking for those little micro
tears those micro tears allow our
muscles to grow and strengthen a similar
process essentially occurs with our
bones so when we strength train we put
our bones under some minor stress and
that stress allows our bones to rebuild
and strengthen this process is called
osteogenesis now to begin osteogenesis
you need some kind of mechanical load on
your bone so usually this is some kind
of like strength training weights
something heavy that you need to pick up
so you don't need to do hit in order to
improve your bones if that does not suit
your body this right here would not work
for me
resistance training is really important
at any age well we know that our bones
are fully formed by about the age of 25
we know that lifting weights can help
keep our bones strong and prevent
osteoporosis resistance training can
also reduce the risk of Falls and
breaking bones which in turn can improve
your quality of life
bottom line lifting heavy up is good for
you so
what do you do for a living I lift
things up and put them down excuse me I
lift things up and put them down
love-love-love pokeballs I mean bowls
are super trendy and I admittedly uber
eats these prices way more than I should
but I love them because they're
inherently pretty well balanced you've
got your protein your veggies your fat
in your carbs and the proteins
particularly important post-workout to
help prepare and build muscles and she's
getting an ideal amount about 30 grams
which is really the optimal amount that
our body can utilize for muscle protein
synthesis I also love that she's not
skimping out on the carbs I think a lot
of people think that post worker is just
about the protein but carbs actually
lists it a little bit of an insulin
response that helps drive the protein
into the muscle to help aid in recovery
faster so I love it all right let's hit
up another snack
I mean smoothies are great I don't think
we should rely on them exclusively every
day but they're a great way to sneak in
some extra produce especially if you
were like really busy on the go and
considering that Natasha doesn't even
have time to poop in the morning I guess
this fits her lifestyle pretty well
having said that I think it's important
to note that a lot of smoothie bowls
particularly the store-bought ones tend
to be really high in sugar yes of course
the sugar is coming from natural sources
like fruit which is great but if we're
not pairing it with adequate protein and
or fat or if those fruits are kind of
like the lower fiber fruits like bananas
and mango which is typical we can still
see a little bit of a blood sugar spike
and drop off if you're making a smoothie
bowl at home which is great I recommend
adding some Greek yogurt or tofu as your
base that's going to add your protein
you could some nut butter in there as
some fats maybe add some vegetables in
there and try to stick to just one or
two servings of fruit all right girl I'm
hungry Phoebe dinner
this looks so good I love that natasha
is adding so many colorful vegetables to
her stir-fry here we got carrots and
peppers and chilies and and Pak Choi so
much good stuff going on I also love
that she's got some plant-based protein
in the form of tofu here really really
great source of protein and I think a
lot of people have concerns about soy
but I want you to know that the research
has found that it is completely safe
so I contains compounds called
isoflavones which is the type of
phytoestrogen that mildly mimics our
body's natural estrogen however there's
no strong evidence to suggest that
consuming foods that are rich in soy
causes any kind of hormonal diseases or
disruptions or any other side effects in
fact some research suggests that may
actually have a protective effect
against diseases like heart disease and
some types of cancer like prostate
ovarian and breast cancer I have a whole
video all about that right here this
looks like a pretty well-balanced meal
to me we've got some protein and some
fiber that'll help keep us satisfied and
some carbohydrates from the glass
noodles looks totally YUM I really like
the Natasha experiments in the kitchen I
think that healthy eating does not need
to be complicated it does not need to
look like an Instagram worthy dish every
single night and I also think it's a fun
way to kind of bond with your partner
try new foods and get away from eating
the same thing every single night
need a chair for a glass you story have
different temperatures I do the same
with little indoor so I have some at
room temperature and that can vary right
now there's about 30 degrees oh my god
girl you know it is the best put a
caramel bar in the freezer and then when
you take it out you put it in your mouth
frozen and like the caramel kind of
heats up and explodes in your mouth my
grandpa used to do it all the time and
every single time I have a caramel bar I
think of him just I I need to try it
girl do this with me now if I can get
into it we'll all be okay okay that's
the best that film day ever all right
move along okay but seriously
Natasha's definitely made a lot of
improvement in her relationship with
food I love that she is like fully
invested in her chocolate game and
despite the fact that she's an active
part of the fitness community where
let's be real macros are life I like
that she's not afraid to be a little bit
flexible with her diet on that note
let's pull up the macros so Natasha is
consuming about 2,250 calories 59% of
which are from carbs 27% from fat and
14% from protein so let's talk about
what we liked about Natasha's day so
first of all it looks like she's getting
enough calories Natasha is an active
girl and I mean those workouts look
super super tough and I love that she's
not afraid to eat in a way that fuels
her body and supports her workouts
number two she's got a great varied diet
I love that I was seeing a nice wide
variety of foods and nothing is
specifically or explicitly demonized
here I'm seeing a ton of different
vegetables
rude protein good fats and even some
chocolate so looks really balanced to me
number three
she doesn't demonize dessert now
speaking of chocolate I feel like this
is the only influencer that I've
reviewed who doesn't consume dessert or
chocolate and talk about it as a guilty
pleasure or lament about how they're
being so bad but rather she's really fun
about it she even talks about the kind
of essential experience of eating
chocolate which is ultimately what
intuitive eating is all about and number
four she isn't afraid to eat out this to
me is key most or thematts ate at least
a few meals a week out of the house some
people are so busy they eat all of their
meals outside the house I'm not saying
that we should be aspiring to never cook
at home again I'm just saying that it's
really refreshing to see an influencer
particularly one in the fitness
community where let's be real it's all
about following meal plans and macros
really really strictly and religiously
be able to just go out order a meal
enjoy whatever portion of it they're in
the mood for and move on and then
finally let's talk about what I think
Natasha can maybe work on so I really
could only think of one thing and that
was that there's still a lot of weight
loss talk on her Channel I'm really
happy to see that Natasha's made
attempts to focus more on intuitive
eating and I actually think she's doing
a really awesome job at listening and
responding to her body's needs while
still incorporating some gentle
nutrition into her day also talks about
how she's now more focused on
performance rather than aesthetics which
i think is great however if you look at
some of our videos there is still a lot
of talk about kind of weight loss and
metabolism etc so I think she's made a
lot of great progress on her intuitive
eating journey I think we still have a
little bit longer to go when it comes to
completely rejecting the diet mentality
overall I really applaud Natasha for
having this amazing great attitude
towards food exercise and body image as
with Stephanie better more I can fully
appreciate that it's not easy to take a
moderate balanced approach in the
fitness industry so I'm really hoping
that Natasha and others can help us move
towards a broader social shift so guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me
comment below with a youtuber that you
want me to review subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]